strike it's a toolkit that can monetize
virtually any online business model it's
api's or like low-level building blocks
that can be used to accept payments
manage customers handle recurring
subscriptions and more lyft uses it to
take payments from riders and payout
drivers digitalocean uses it to sell a
metered software-as-a-service product
and Shopify uses it to implement a
massive online marketplace it's
extremely popular with startups because
of its developer first approach instead
of worrying about things like compliance
security and fraud detection you can
focus on the user experience and
implement your payment system with just
a few API calls so how does a credit
card payment work when a user is ready
to make a payment in your app you'll
first need to create a payment intent on
your server the payment intent is kind
of like a session that manages the
payment process currently it's in a
state of requires payment method step
two is obtaining the credit card details
or payment method from the customer you
can handle this process securely on the
web using stripe j/s it's able to mount
a customizable credit card forum
directly in your application it
automatically validates the users input
so you don't have to worry about
implementing your own form validation
and all the edge cases that go along
with it when the form is submitted
you'll write a function that takes the
payment intent from your server combines
it with the credit card details entered
by the user in the browser then calls
stripe confirm card payment to send this
data off to stripe servers it will
attempt to finalize the payment but many
parts of the world now have regulations
in place that require additional
authorization for the payment the
payment intent now has a status of
requires action a strike will handle
this process for you entirely in the
front end and once complete your payment
intent will move to a status of
succeeded congratulations you've just
been paid but you're not done just yet
you still need to fulfill the product
somehow anytime something important
happens in the stripe API like when a
payment intent succeeds you can listen
to these events by setting up web hooks
when the event occurs stripe will send
this data to your server so you can
handle it accordingly like updating your
apps database or printing out a shipping
label this has been stripe payments in
100 seconds if you're serious about
monetizing your product consider
enrolling in my brand new stripe
JavaScript course thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one
[Music]